صعب جدا يا جماعه انا اتخطر على كل الناس
ترجمه لصرخاتي يتيم ووضع صعب في دار
الايتام هنا باختصار رضاع يناشدون على
طريقتهم
امبارح هم لا يدركون لكن ثمه تداعيات حرب
حاضره فوق رؤوسهم وفي امعائهم ايضا
اطفال توفوا جوعا في الخرطوم رصه الجثث
تباعا خلال شهرين الماضيين سبعون يتيما
رضيعا واطفال اكبر سنا لم يقاوموا تداعيات
الجوع اكثر
ايتام في دور اخرى محظوظون قوافل للامم
المتحده جاءت لاجلائهم شيء من السكينه
للاطفال وللعاملون ايضا
نحن سعداء حقا اننا استطعنا تنفيذ هذا
الاجلاء ويمكننا كمنظمه محايده تنفيذ
عمليات اخرى استطعنا الحصول على جميع
الضمانات الامنيه
اجلاء تحقق بنجاح لكن الاطفال لم تتاثر
اجسادهم فقط بل يعانون من امراض عقليه
ونفسيه جراء الحرب
كان من المحزن حقا ان نرى كل هؤلاء
الاطفال يعاني بعضهم من حاله صحيه عقليه
وحالات صحيه اخرى
تسارعت عمليات الانقاذ بعد ارتفاع معدلات
الوفيات حالتين الى اربع يوميا فيما توفي
50 طفلا وعشرون رضيعا منهم 13 توفوا دفعه
واحده في السادس والعشرين من مايو الماضي
اطفال وان قاوموا يواجهون الان مستشفيات
خاويه لا ترعى غيداء السالم العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات